[Music]
absolutely max congratulations a
confident victory i have to stay you
started off the first two games it felt
like you had some chances in those ones
as well i was winning in game one
by a full pawn and i was just thinking
to myself how not to repeat what i did
in round one because i was winning after
14 moves and
then i
had so many possibilities that they just
swarmed my head and i couldn't figure
out
because they all looked winning so i
just couldn't make decisions you're such
an experienced player how do you deal
with those type of situations uh
the experience comes also with practice
and that i didn't have for quite some
time so
but
i
for this game at least i tried to think
back to game to round one and and try to
avoid what happened round one let's take
a look at this game it felt like you got
a devastating position after 10 moves of
play yeah so i was winning after nine
moves yeah
was your first instinct when you saw
this move were you shocked i was shocked
i was like you know this is not this is
not playable this cannot be playable uh
i mean i think i think black is worried
about queen a5 bishop takes knight yes
uh which is the main idea really and
then maybe i don't know after rook takes
bishop maybe queen d4 i don't know did
you still have some idea some
preparations yeah there's some prep
stuff i mean i've played this so many
times
but uh
yeah
and and certainly the move before that
black should could take with a knight
and go into slightly worse but pl
absolutely playable position knight
takes knight takes pawn takes and after
d takes c
queen a5 check
uh followed by queen takes c5 c3 here
and then queen check and queen takes
pawn and white is a little bit better
but you know it's absolutely playable
for black one more question because it
does seem like you're quite experienced
with uh this particular position do you
know what the name of it is
even the london system no no no this
particular e4 variation oh no i don't
it's called the steinitz counter gambit
apparently the tiniest counter game with
my gun okay we have no idea
i love playing counter games my favorite
opening when i was a kid was the fog
bear counter again but so you know here
it
is
okay
a little bit more ridiculous but uh yeah
this is yeah of course d5 has been
played in some famous games back in like
1910 and stuff but um
i think after pawn takes pawn white has
a slight edge so um and then he played
this move bishop to g4 yeah this was uh
really yeah so i mean actually actually
before h3 i was thinking maybe you know
because i was trying to make use of the
fact that black cannot go knight d7 ever
because if he goes knight d7 i'll play
c6 and bishop a6 which is will win the
rook on eight so i thought about f3 here
uh and then and then taking and castling
yes and so that the knight d7 i have
pawn takes pawn followed by c6 with this
idea that they just outlined yes uh and
yeah this is kind of
not i mean not i don't know this doesn't
look pretty probably by just go ahead
and this is over well sorry
but
so but i thought he'd go bishop d7
anyway because that's the only really
square i thought
i saw for him
um so yeah
i mean still you wanted to take that one
on e4 for free but yeah but like still
this is like come on i mean okay could
this be really playable i mean i don't
know i don't think so but but so again i
had a choice but i said okay you know
let's let's play simple this time
uh not to repeat my game against dmitry
and uh and because now i'm just winning
a pawn
and and and then i was like yeah yeah
night yeah again i thought okay 92 but
like
why uh because i thought if the knight
gets to f3 it's actually going to be
stronger so eventually i just took and
then i was like okay what's he going to
figure out how
where is the counter play coming from so
exactly he's he actually
thought of one idea right which is
g6 i think he well first yeah
g6
and then and this is was like the final
i think um calculation that i had to
figure out what to do in his setup and i
saw this idea bishop d2 bishop c3 which
wins another pawn basically very nice
yeah and and and i don't i don't i don't
see what he could do i don't know maybe
no the position after bishop g4 yeah and
and this was a little trick that he
obviously in 94 but that doesn't work
because i double my rooks when he trades
on d4 and goes f5 i just play rook
d1
and you know game over and if he plays
rookie five to double rooks then i just
have rookie three for example
uh
and yeah no no no yeah rookie three
bricks e5 should be uh seven
mm-hmm yeah i mean for example this is
nice
yeah and yeah the key is always to have
two extra pawns on one side then that's
what i was trying for against dimitri
and i
kept failing horribly
blundered but um
uh i think i blundered about five
different wins in that year
plus or minus two
[Laughter]
so yeah but yeah here i just kept all
the counter play at bay basically and
and here was another idea that to just
put the work on e5
and to trade bishops on d5 after that it
seemed
extremely simple
um
yeah and nothing much that black could
really do and he kind of
i don't know maybe i have to go for this
one but i i always thought
bishop endings up a pawn are actually
easier to win than broken border next
but yeah this is but uh yeah i just
opened the game up
i just kept moving things up until yeah
until sure it's time to resign yeah
because on bishop c bishop f5 snuffs it
so
max a very dominant uh victory for you
now we were wondering what are you doing
uh nowadays you're not playing too much
what what are you i i run my uh my chess
academies uh we have three locations
already open but the plan is to actually
open up like 20 30 locations
in uh tri-state area and then forward
you know towards you know the whole
country um and also i just started a
project called chessreach.com
which is basically
a way to
get all the professional chess players
to
offer their services for a minimum
high price
basically the idea is to raise uh
raise the
the pricing on lessons uh and the
ability to take you know
play with grandmasters and iams and
title players and so if anybody wants to
register on chessreach.com either as a
student or as a title player we welcome
that there it's open
and you can just put your time that you
are available the pricing that you like
as long as it meets the minimum criteria
which is quite high
um and uh off you go you know you can
get yourself a student or or or learn
from someone really good definitely a
busy man keeping busy congratulations
max congratulations for the game and
we'll see you in the rest of your games
thank you
max two questions for you please sure uh
repeat it's
www chess
reach that's on reaching out reaching
out
and that's where people can get in touch
yeah they they can get they can find
they uh fill out their profile whether
they're a coach
a title player
it starts with fms goes up to gms
and
or they can fill out their profile as a
student what they're looking for and
they'll be set up with they'll be
matched yeah we're
it's a soft launch for now but once it
gets off there'll be a lot of matches
second it's like a dating service for
learning tests
second question for you
how do you overcome the depression of
letting an opponent off the hook
just like you did with dimitri in the
first round i straightened it easily
very easily i i did the same with black
yesterday and so i felt very good okay
but uh but generally
i'm basically thinking about the
uh tournament three years ago where i
started with one out of six and then
finished with three wins in a row and i
thought you know if i don't start with
uh that kind of score in this term that
i should be happy right because maybe
maybe i have it in me to win a couple
games down the road some lovely good
luck nice to see you thank you